if Y is equal to one, and similarly, Alice performs this gate right
here if X is equal to zero, and this gate right here,
if X is equal to one.
So, that is Alice and Bob's strategy and now we just need to
figure out how well it works.
For the analysis of the quantum strategy that I just described, we
really only need two things at this point, first, the
unitary matrix U Theta
is as you see right here, and
second we had this formula.
We don't actually even need the definition of the vector si theta anymore, these two equations are all we need.
There are four cases to
consider starting with case one, which is that X equal
zero and Y equals zero.
And if we look back at the strategy, we'll find that in this
case Alice performs U zero on her qubit and Bob performs
U pi over eight on his qubit.
Remember, Alice is on the
bottom and Bob is on the top, so the state that they
obtain looks like this.
And by expanding that out
according to the definition of U theta, we get this
expression you see right here.
We don't need to expand
that out any further because we have the other
formula to help us out.
And if we apply that formula
for each of the four terms, what we get is this.
At this point Alice and Bob both measure and here's a table that
explains the distribution of the outcomes.
We take the absolute value
squared of the coefficients to get the probabilities, which happens to be the
squares of the coefficients
because the coefficients are
all real numbers in this case.
If we make use of the
sine and cosine values from earlier in the lesson
along with some symmetries, we can express these probabilities
as we have right here
in the last column.
Now, what we really care
about is the probability that they win, and remember that, in the case that X and Y are both zero,
they win if A and B are equal and they lose if A and B are not equal.
If we calculate those probabilities, we find that the probability
that A and B are equal is the sum of this number and this number,
which is equal to two plus
root two all over four, which is about 85%.
The probability that A and B are not equal is two minus root two all over four, which is naturally one minus the quantity
that we just calculated, so
they win with probability about 85% in this case.
There are three more cases to consider, but they're all very similar to this one,
in the case that X equals
zero and Y equals one, Bob applies U negative pi over eight rather than U pi over eight,
the values in the
formulas change somewhat, but we end up with exactly
the same probabilities that we had in the previous case.
When X equals zero and Y equals one, Alice and Bob still win
when A and B are equal and so we have exactly the
same winning probability
as before.
In the third case, when X is equal to one and Y is equal to zero, we
have a similar situation, the angles are different,
but they have exactly
the same relationship to
one another, and in fact, we do get exactly the
same vector that we got in the previous case.
So the probabilities are the same and so is the winning probability.
The last case is a little bit
different as we might expect because the winning condition
is different in this case.
When X and Y are both equal to one, Alice and Bob win when
A and B are different.
The basic method is the same, although the angles are different, this time, we get this vector right here
and you can check that by going through the required subtractions.
The probabilities do change finally, and if we look up the values that we need, we see that the probabilities
have effectively
swapped positions from before, so this time it's the probability
that A is not equal to B, that is the larger of the two,
but that's good because in this case, Alice and Bob win when
A and B are not equal.
So once again, they win with
probability approximately 85%.
Given that they win in every
case with the same probability, which is two plus root two
all over four or about 85%,
that's the probability
that they win overall.
That's better than any classical strategy can do for this game, and that's
what makes it interesting.
This happens to be the
optimal winning probability for any quantum strategy, you
can't do any better than this using any entangled state.
That fact is known Tsirelson inequality, it's named named for Boris
Tsirelson who first proved it, and to my knowledge was
one of the first people
to describe this example as a game. In case the analysis
that we just went through seems a little bit mysterious,
it's possible to think
about it geometrically, which might be helpful to
give you a better sense for the choice of the angles.
Specifically, if we use the
formula that you see right here, which we can easily deduce
from the expressions
we already found for the
inner products involved, then we can alternatively
express the probabilities of the different possible
measurement outcomes